All systems of oppression are highly
adaptive and they can adapt to
challenges and incorporate them.
They can allow for exceptions.
And I think the most effective
adaptation of the system of racism to
the challenges of the civil rights
movement was to reduce a racist to a
very simple formula.
A racist is an individual,
always an individual,
not a system who consciously does not
like people based on race must be
conscious and who intentionally seeks to
be mean to them.
Individual conscious intent.
And if that is my definition of a
racist,
then your suggestion that anything I've
said or done is racist or has a racist
impact,
I'm going to hear that.
As you just said,
I was a bad person.
You just put me over there in that
category.
And most of my bias anyway is
unconscious.
So I,
I'm not intending,
I'm not aware.
Uh,
so now I'm going to need to defend my
moral character and,
and I will,
and we've all seen it.
It seems to be virtually impossible
based on that definition for the average
white person to look deeply at their
socialization,
to look at the inevitability of
internalizing racist biases,
developing racist patterns,
and having investments in the system of
racism,
which is pretty comfortable for us and
serves us really well.
I think that definition of a racist that
either,
or what I call the good,
bad binary is the root of virtually all
white defensiveness on this topic
because it makes it virtually impossible
to talk to the average white person
about the inevitable absorption of a
racist worldview that we get by being
literally swimming in racist water.
So let me connect that to myself as a
result of being raised as a white person
in this society.
I have a racist world view,
I have deep racist biases,
I have developed a racist patterns and I
have investments in the system of racism
because it's,
it's served me really well.
It's comfortable.
It's helped me overcome the,
the barriers that I do face.
And I also have an investment and not
seeing any of that for what it would
suggest to me about my identity.
And what it would require of me.
Right?
I didn't choose any of that.
I don't feel guilty about it is an
inevitable result of being raised in
this society in which racism is the
bedrock.
The question of guilt comes in in,
what am I doing about that?
While we who are white tend to be
fragile in that it doesn't take much to
upset us around race.
The impact of our response is not
fragile at all.
It's a kind of weaponized defensiveness,
weaponized,
hurt feelings,
right?
And it functions really,
really effectively to repel the
challenge.
You know,
as a white person,
I moved through the world racially
comfortable,
virtually 24 seven.
It is exceptional for me to be outside
of my racial comfort zone and most of my
life I've been warned not to go outside
my racial comfort zone.
And so on the rare occasion when I am
uncomfortable racially,
it's,
it's a kind of throwing off of my racial
equilibrium and I need to get back into
that.
And so I will do whatever it takes to
repel the challenge and get back into
it.
And in that way,
I think white fragility functions as a
kind of white racial bullying.
To be frank,
we make it so miserable for people of
color to talk to us about are inevitable
and often unaware racist patterns that
we cannot help develop,
uh,
from being socialized into a culture in
which racism is the bedrock and the
foundation.
We make it so miserable for them to talk
to us about it that most of the time
they don't.
I mean,
it just mean we just have to understand
that most people of color that are
working or living in primarily white
environment take home way more daily
slights and hurts and insults than they
bother talking to us about
because their experiences,
they're going to risk more punishment.
They're going to lose the relationship.
They're going to have their experience
minimized,
explained away.
They're going to cause the person to
feel attacked or hurt.
And in that way,
white fragility functions as a kind of
everyday white racial control.
None of that has to be intentional or
conscious,
but that is how it functions and it's
actually incredibly liberating and
transformative to start from the premise
that of course I've internalized all of
this and then I can stop defending,
deflecting,
denying,
hoping you won't notice,
minimize and explaining.
And I can just let go of that and get to
work.
And there's a question that's never
failed me in my efforts to unpack.
How do we pull this off?
How do so many of us who are white
individually feel so free of racism?
And yet we live in a society that is so
profoundly separate and unequal by race.
And the question that's never failed me
is not,
is this true or is this false?
Is this right?
Or is this wrong?
But how does it function?
How do these narratives that I tell,
how do they function when I tell you,
well,
I'm just an individual.
Why can't we all just be individuals?
When I tell you I was taught to treat
everyone the same when I tell you,
but it's focusing on race that divides
us when I tell you,
but I have lots of friends of color.
Those narratives have not changed our
outcome,
and they function to take race off the
table and to exempt the person from any
further engagement and then doing that,
they function to protect the current
racial hierarchy in the white position
within it.
It doesn't have to be what I'm intending
to do,
but it is the impact of those
narratives.